العضويه في جامعه الدول العربيه بدات بسبع
دول حين تاسست واتسعت لاحقا على مر
السنوات لتشمل اثنتين وعشرين دوله
تنقسم العضويه في جامعه الدول العربيه الى
نوعين هما عضويه اصليه وعضويه بالانضمام
العضويه الاصليه هي مثبته للدول المستقله
السبعه التي وقعت على ميثاق جامعه الدول
العربيه
اما العضويه بالانضمام فهي تشمل بقيه
الدول المنضمه لاحقا
ويؤكد ميثاق الجامعه على حق كل دوله عربيه
مستقله في الانضمام اليها بعد تقديم طلب
وموافقه الاعضاء بالاجماع
ميثاق الجامعه يتيح ايضا للدول الاعضاء
الانسحاب من العضويه اضافه الى فصل او طرد
دوله بالاجماع
علقت الجامعه العربيه عضويه ثلاث دول هي
مصر وسوريا وليبيا قبل ان تعيد عضويه هذه
الدول في اوقات لاحقه اخرها سوريا في
السابع من مايو الحالي
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات